one more drink one more
drink you know in the morning
for sure we gonna stink one more
round one more round
it's
[Music]
this is what we do catch up for a few
we'll riff and talk some [ __ ] and then
we'll sleep till too
[Music]
hey here we are sunday this the sun is
shining it's beautiful out in new york
city and we're inside and there are
caves
drinking liquor you hear this sound
was that a fat tire it's a fat tire baby
i love fat tire i'm a native american
with my ear on the tracks i could just
see that cap and hear that
click and i knew it was a fat tire i
wasn't even showing you the label that
was pretty impressive
oh i used to drink a lot
i still do apparently but yeah i love
fat tire underrated
underrated and it's what detective bosch
drinks
bosch is like he eats well if you
haven't seen that show it's like perfect
because it's like
it's like a detective who's got the
sweetest department ever overlooking
los angeles and he just got it because
he the the back story is that he
uh he consulted on like some movie back
in the day in hollywood and that got him
the money to have a sweet pad so he's
like
he can't climb the ranks because he
breaks all the rules but he's still got
a sweet apartment
that's such a great little backstory fro
for a tv show
because every tv show has this insane
apartment like especially in new york
like the friends women have that amazing
apartment
and one of them's a coffee shop lady or
whatever one's this musician
barely like that's like a six million
dollar apartment
yeah it's ridic i love that uh i love
that you have a good backstory i also
love
shows like bosh where it's like every
character is angry like every character
and every scene is in a bad mood like
every detective walks in like [ __ ] you
santiago
that's not like every scene starts i
love it so true
uh yeah i tried i watched that show it's
great
and my uh i watch it with my lady and
she was like i don't get it
i'm like what are you kidding this
show's awesome this guy's a badass
it's all about you know noir detective
los angeles and she was like
i just seems like a grump i was like
he's a girl
he's always in a bad mood he's always in
a bad mood i love it
yeah yeah i love everything it's never
like daylight they're never by a pool
there's never kids playing it's just
night murder chalk out line and like a
scotch
i have a question for you because i have
an upset stomach right now i and it's
like
it's funny how i like so i did like
spicy thai food i did i stayed in last
night i did a zoom with a bunch of
friends from college yeah and went like
four hours so i went through like a
bottle of wine
i still count that as drinking alone by
the way it is
yeah that's assumed you're not fooling
me with that
oh i mean but you know what i it's like
it was like a four hour zoom and you're
like [ __ ] this is
i don't know if it's like more tiring
because by the last hour i was yawning
every like
30 seconds yeah and i'm like i don't
know if like i think the zoom hang is
way more exhausting because you're just
staring at a screen
it's not like if i was just hanging with
him in a room i think it would have been
fine but like the zoom
the zoom hang is tough i completely
agree because
you're you're on a screen so yeah you
have to be performing and it's all face
to face
not much else is face to face for four
hours you know you can kind of look off
to the side you put a tv show on you're
drinking
whatever it is but that is just locked
in
for the whole time it's weird because
everyone talks about like working remote
and how it's going to be the new normal
after this but it's like
sometimes it's just nice to be around
humans man i [ __ ] i'm i i'm
i love that we're like with you it's it
does it's not as hard because i think
we're just
we got a thing yeah but i mean this
would be easier in person we'll get it
going in person once the fat black opens
maybe
yeah so you got the comedy cellar behind
you got the olive tree baby
that's nice yeah i uh i completely agree
i think you gotta get out you gotta
mingle you gotta
be around pheromones and people have
energies and vibes and all that [ __ ] is
it's it's like phone sex versus regular
sex you know like
phone sex has its place you can still
get a boner but
i mean without the hot breath and the
tinge of b.o
and a queef or whatever it is it's it's
not
it's not living it's not the same right
not the queef
it's you know it's true yeah it's it's
some i was speaking of sex i think this
summer is gonna be like
[ __ ] woodstock don't you think like
people are just gonna be like
yeah i'll [ __ ] that guy what the hell
like the you know totally i mean this is
the time to be single it's gonna be
roaring twenties
it's gonna be sunshine and uh no condoms
no mask
we're gonna double down because we
there's been so much built up
uh what do you call it repressed i'm
going two condoms two masks
i call it the uh the fouchy deluxe i
uh no i i uh yeah i think this summer's
gonna be completely crazy people are
gonna be bottled up they're gonna be
going nuts i think like
block parties might be coming back oh
shit's gonna be crazy
oh yeah yeah all that [ __ ] like sewing
circles and like
hanging out on the porch and picnics
picnics are gonna be big
all that [ __ ] in the park is coming back
beach stuff it's gonna be wild
what are you drinking by the way oh yeah
i went uh
old fashioned oh look at that i like the
that's a nice glass dude thank you thank
you yeah i got a set for like a
housewarming gift once and
i still use them old-fashioned what kind
of what kind of uh bourbon you're using
i went with the tealys is that right
don't know it it's an irish
it's actually an irish whiskey a
t-e-e-l-y-s
i might have said jamie lynn gave it to
me oh she rules shout out jamie lynn
yeah um i double check i got that right
tealy whiskey oh [ __ ]
i don't want to piss her off tealing
tealing
sorry healing not tealy tealing but it's
pretty damn good
yeah dude alcohol is good i take the i
don't put the sugar cube in it
so it's not as you know girly
i want less sugar in my alcohol that's
like mine i i just
and it's like because if you have one
it's fine but if you have like four
you're like all right now i have like a
sugar high you know yes
exactly well let me let me go back to
the uh the zoom thing for a minute
because this is fascinating to me what
the hell do you guys do for four hours
are you playing
go fish are you talking about movies or
you have games what is it
everything you know you know no no games
we're just catching up i mean i haven't
seen them forever i feel like i'm the
guy who missed out on a lot of stuff
because i was doing comedy so i
i missed the weddings i missed you know
this because i was
doing like i can't not take this gig
when i'm starting out so
uh so i feel like i gotta show up you
know
yeah yeah you kind of get it all out in
one
one a big full blowout four hours here
you go i haven't seen you in six months
yeah i mean i think that's kind of how
you got to do it these days that's the
weird thing too is like
now that this has become the new normal
zoom
you kind of catch up with more and more
people that you just never saw
yeah and that and that's draining
totally
totally yeah yeah it really is like
i guess it's like my parents you know
when i lived at home i stayed up in my
room
they annoyed the [ __ ] out of me and i
barely saw him and then when i moved to
new york they're calling me every day
because they're nervous they're freaking
out or you're out of the house now
talk to us and i was like i don't want
to keep recording you
what's that you talk to them every day
no no but my mom will text and be like
oh your brother
uh read this book he thought you might
like it i'm like it's a book about
coding
yeah well you got me there mom
there's an article about roseanne in the
uh the new yorker i'm like
so what she's like well she's a comedian
i'm like oh jeez i get a lot of those
yeah it's nice yeah they mean well but
it's also very
it's it's like the least amount of
effort you can do like hey i saw
joy behar uh tripped and fell on 48th
street
you should hear about that she's a
comedian i'm like joy baker
come on we're scraping the barrel here
uh yeah i know my folks do that too
anything in the new york times about
comedy and it's like
you know i've i've seen it probably like
if it's in the new york times on comedy
i'm like
it's been passed around our community
but it's i like it's cute that they do
it
but uh what uh you were in cincinnati
cincinnati just got back today it was
one of those [ __ ]
flights where they're like you can take
the 7am or the 7pm i'm like give me this
seven let's just get it over with and
then the airport is an hour away
from the from the hotel because that
club right
yeah it's in kentucky and that club is
in the [ __ ] burps
so not only if you get there an hour
early you gotta leave an hour early to
get there an hour early so you just you
could kill yourself on sleep and then we
watch the ufc fight which doesn't end
till 2 a.m
is it like that's what i hate when these
clubs are kind of like we're in
cincinnati and then they're like it's
like it's like the people were like i'm
from new york city and you're like where
and they're like
long island you're like all right just
say new york then just yeah
yes there's a lot of new jersey well you
get old you get an older crowd
too so you're expecting downtown
cincinnati you're getting like the young
people but is cincinnati's skyline
chilly is that their thing that's it
that was my opener every night uh
skyline jokes chilly jokes shooting
blood
miscarriage yadda yadda but not only the
older but these are like
older suburbanite christian
conservative which look i'm fine with i
don't give a [ __ ] what you are i'm glad
you came out but like
i got eight minutes on how god is stupid
and uh
biden smelling children and all this
[ __ ] in there it was a little heavy
you take a bible out you start wiping
your ass with it you're like no this is
my closure you guys got to see this it's
good
yeah yeah exactly it's meta it's ironic
but they weren't having i kind of had a
couple walkouts always weird you're like
man i had a great set this crowd loved
me i killed all right and then i get to
the
the green room and they're like all
right good we got one more show about 28
people walked out on that when i'm like
what
you know because it's so dark but hey
better to not know
do they do comment cards no i think
i think that's over i don't know i
remember i used to
i i used to read them i was like let me
see the bad ones save the because i make
they make me like it'd be like twitter
for even older people you know what i
mean it was like
it was kind of funny but uh yeah that's
so you notice i'm walking as you as
you're eating [ __ ] no i i didn't notice
them and
that's what i'm saying like i was like
that went great and then they would be
like oh yeah but they would just be
trying to start up a conversation like
hey about 28 people walked i hope i hope
it didn't bother you i'm like i didn't
know that
jesus maybe i should tone it down that's
[ __ ] hilarious you walked 28 people
yeah one show i mean there's there's a
you know
150 in there so that's a good chunk
that is a big chunk i got i got a cool i
think i'm you know
you know what it is the hour is new
we're trying to find new materials so
you tend to say more [ __ ] you tend to
go dirtier because you're like i need
some reaction this is all
barely finished material that's so yeah
that's interesting i feel the same way
it's like you kind of when you're
writing a new hour it's like you know
you get to like you get like 50 minutes
of ideas and then you go back out and
you're like all right i'm down to 35.
yes even got potential and then you're
like all right well really it's like 25.
right then you kind of got to start
building back up and you're like yes
all right i mean so it's like you're
right you're going for those like shock
laughs i do it all the time
like i just need some reaction so
there's not silence
exactly so you're like man i'm killing
with this anal bit
but about having [ __ ] on my dick but
then you're like wait do i want to be
that guy you know
if seinfeld calls again i can't bring
that to the beacon
you know so yeah you just do it out of
uh
desperation and like you're just trying
to cling at straws uh whatever gets a
laugh
you know i'm trying to entertain these
people and then eventually it kind of
slides off as you start writing better
[ __ ]
well that's the thing is like jerry
would always say that like he could
write a
he could write a dirty hour if if like
because he you know he plays the hits
but then
yeah i could write a dirty hour once a
year yeah
yeah i kind of want to hear jerry's
dirty alley oh
man would that be great what's the deal
with foreskin
you know or what's going on with
threesomes
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
if it's two people it's not a twosome
why do we go threesome
that would be hilarious dirty seinfeld
yes
it's not like a cigarette i want to see
seinfeld destroy
heckler oh shut up you're a [ __ ] you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh that would be great one day
one day one day what's up with the
fleshlight it's not flesh
do you put this in a dishwasher
yeah it is funny that like then you
think about you're like [ __ ]
cosby is the cleanest comic and you're
like you could have had some dirty bits
that's true yeah yeah very in-depth [ __ ]
like wow
i didn't know you could do that osby's
wife was always so mad at him in every
bit
and it's like it's like is she really
this mad at you over like toothpaste and
then you're like
oh you were raping everyone you left
there that's why my cosby's material
didn't add up for me you're like why is
camille this mad at you over aftershave
it's not the aftershave it's the [ __ ]
drugs in the bag that he's carrying
around
it's the the chloroform
[Laughter]
yeah yeah that's true so yeah you gotta
go dirty just to just uh
just to get a pop also in the [ __ ]
midwest in a strip mall it's like
i always respected people like ryan
hamilton or like clean comics who like
that friday late show clean
that's gotta be tough that is very
impressive i just watched the regan hour
by the way have you seen it it is i saw
clips that were really funny is it great
pretty good it's pretty damn good it's
so weird you're like wow this is good
material
it that's how bad stand-up specials have
got and i watched it i was like this is
great that's a great bit that's a great
bit
it was almost surprising which is a
horrible sign
yeah he's a legend yeah it was great and
he also had a leather jacket and i was
like oh here we go
this is gonna be bad but it was great to
light a cigarette like
yeah hickory dickory dock like reagan
yeah he uh he's [ __ ] great man
that original album i remember his half
hour so great i mean like
kill her so many people do him have you
have you met him before
oh yeah coolest guy i always tell this
story
he'll do some theater in a city and then
he'll just be bored and he likes to
party a little bit so he'll be bored
and i saw him in the back of my show at
the
charlotte comedy zone i was like is that
brian regan
just hanging back there drinking and i
was like hey man what's up and he goes
hey i didn't know where to go so i just
come to the comedy club you guys want a
drink
and he bought everybody drinks we hung
out all night yeah i had a similar
experience in
jamestown new york lucy fest he came in
the room
watched my set we we drank after he
couldn't have been a cooler guy
loved him great guy great guy i'm sure
on some level it's like he knows
that it's cool that we're like oh brian
regan you know right
but he has none of that he's just
completely humble salt of the earth cool
dude regular dude you're an equal
or whatever yeah he's he's always his
brother's super funny too dennis regan
i've done i hear that
yeah he's he's a great he's done a bunch
of letterman's he said he i saw him do a
joke where he goes uh my dad one of them
uh reversible belts
you know when i was a kid on one side it
was brown and on the other side he would
he would beat me with it
he's like darker brian regan i like it
deadpan yeah
but uh yeah i hate to say it but oh
sorry
oh no what i think going clean is is a
is more skill oh yeah some people
will negate that they don't like that
okay but it depends also end of the day
it's
funny that matters so like how hard so
it's like
you know what makes you laugh the
hardest like yeah
going completely clean you're you're
there's less of a crutch so of course
it's harder but you definitely judge by
the funniest hour i think
yeah yeah i agree an output and how much
you can put out
and it's just so much of the wording and
how you say it like you could have the
funniest thought
about a toaster or what an uber or
whatever it is
but like i'll do them on stage like my
i'm in my hotel room like this is gold
this is a great
observation and then they're like yeah
that is that is interesting and you're
like oh
it's not getting that twist it's not
getting that pop that i want but then
you go
dirty or throw a [ __ ] and it pops
that's not what you want from an
audience you don't want them to go ah
yes keen observation yeah all right
there we go dubai
it's uh it's a skill man i mean ryan
hamilton's got
this great joke about going to i think
it was like disneyland or something he
went to some
amusement park and they said uh so uh
so uh you're alone and he said uh yeah
and they go
just one and ryan goes how far do you
want to take this ah
you see that's a great line that's great
that's what it's all about folks good
friends
one of the funniest who watches netflix
special happy face he's
incredible yes yes he's great what
uh what's bothering you man like what
i'm sure you i know you're getting
peeves on the road you're in [ __ ] you
are no sleep
i'm on no sleep the road peeves when you
hit those uh those flights and the clubs
and the openers and the managers and the
audiences that
all the peeves just flood over you it's
amazing
i got a couple i don't know how many you
want i'll take them i'll take any of
them
all right you've got a few of course
[Laughter]
uh one of them i had a guy doing this
all weekend i'm not gonna say who it was
but it was driving me [ __ ] nuts
and maybe i'm an [ __ ] but he would
say you know what i mean
before finishing the sentence so he was
like
oh man i was at i was at the bus depot
and uh oh i gotta tell you
you know what i mean and i'm like no i
don't because you haven't told me where
we're going here i don't know the
premise
i just know the location i don't know
your angle
so that would drive me nuts because you
you waste energy going oh yeah i know
what you mean yeah yeah but it's a
meaningless you know what i mean
oh there's no man in that's brutal it's
like a pop quiz on a test and you're
like we don't even know what the subject
is yet
exactly exactly so you're you're wasting
you're wasting my time with you know
what i mean because i'm like oh yeah
yeah but i actually don't know what you
mean and now i'm just
validating you constantly and we haven't
even gotten anywhere
interesting drives me nuts uh yeah no
it's really i i
even at the end it's kind of like it is
uh
i've used as a crutch where you say you
know at the end yeah
we talked about this it's like people
who lack confidence in what they're
saying
yeah they're trying to get like verbal
confirmation the same people when
they're talking to you
they can sense your space now so they
start like hitting your chest yeah
yes yes this is a good way to tell a
story uh
light assault this is a good way to get
me to [ __ ] pay attention
yeah ladies it's a [ __ ]
it's like a hostage situation it's
ridiculous yes hey hey and you're like
hey how come you haven't realized that
you're hitting me
that's you sh that should be a cue to
you that your story sucks if you have to
hit the guy
you know like what is that what are you
going to internalize that you're hitting
because your story sucks not because
we're
we're like fading out but yeah look at
i'm an insecure douche just like anybody
else and i need validation too but you
got to earn it folks
that's all i'm saying so you know what i
mean drives me nuts and
i did a years ago i owned for this guy
urban guy
super urban but he kept saying like
jokes jokes jokes know what i mean
joke know what i mean and by the end of
it some guy in the back goes
yes we know what you mean and the place
went
nuts was beautiful on a headliner
yeah oh yeah damn that's that's brutal
it was brutal but i mean like the
kitchen was happy
the staff was happy the comics were
happy the audience was happy i mean it
had to be said
damn yeah i know what you mean yeah at a
certain point we know
we got it we got it or we haven't gotten
it yet so there's nothing to get
you got to get to that part and then
we'll see if we know what you mean
you got to earn the mean you got to earn
this this is another big one people do
they'll tell you something they go does
that make sense and you're like well
maybe you should figure out if it if it
makes sense before you throw it out
there
now we got to decipher i've done it look
we all
we've all done does that make sense yeah
does that make sense
you know what does that mean i don't
know have you are you familiar with the
english language why don't you form a
sentence and come back here when you've
decided if it makes sense
right right and i've done it we've all
done it but some people overdo it
oh they overdo it does this make sense
geez that's a that is an annoying one
that's a big one what do you got hey
does this make sense
uh i ate earlier today and i'm still
hungry
yeah yeah it makes sense complex
thank you thanks for the uh thanks for
this okay what do i have let's see i
have to write them down because
or else i'll forget them all i got uh
okay i got one of my friends
you know him he just moved to jersey
i'll say his name gary veeder i love him
but he here's what he said to me i'm
still right i was mad i was like you're
moving to jersey i'm gonna miss you guys
i'm still right there
yeah he goes i'm 40 minutes without
traffic this bugs me the without traffic
that's good you always give it the width
that you always give me the best case
yes without trouble when are you going
to come visit me at [ __ ] 2 a.m
right exactly 2 a.m on a sunday on
christmas day
he said to me yesterday he came by my
place yesterday and he goes all right
it's 40 minutes out of traffic i'm like
alright when you come by it goes 5 15.
i thought it was 40 minutes that's
great and then it's like the parking
becomes an incident and he's like he
can't relax and he's like i put money in
the meter i got to go and i'm like this
is a whole this is what this is
life now in jersey yeah yeah oh dude
people go hard with that time [ __ ] where
they go door to door that's a big one i
can be there
40 minutes door to door you're like
really door to door
i don't believe you like does that mean
if you have to spend a bunch of time
parking you'll just
you'll just jump out of the car on a
shoulder roll and just i gotta pick
39 minutes i got to run to the door
i think the michael j movie just [ __ ]
crashes yeah
yeah i worked on a construction site
once and uh really
you did yeah i was a gopher i would just
like be the wheelbarrow guy like moving
all the
the demo stuff and uh this guy
kept taking breaks and he was like i
just need i need like five minutes i
need five minutes so eventually the
foreman was like all right i'll give me
five minutes
and he just sat there looking at his
watch and
it was like six minutes seven minutes
and he's like hey what's going on the
guy's like i just need
i need like five minutes he's like it's
already been seven and i
secretly loved it because i was like
[ __ ] you with this
you're five we just say five but nobody
means five and this guy was like all
right you do that again i'm timing you
it's funny that's like a movie star take
five that's a good
on set thing let me take five right you
know but that yeah that's like a diva
thing
yeah it's never five it's just that just
means i need a break some
vague amount of time but this guy was
like i'll give you five but
if you go over five i'm gonna yell you
interesting
maybe ocp liked it give me five is
always [ __ ]
yes i'll [ __ ] you again just give me
five yeah
exactly no i need 30. let's be honest
and i need 30.
yeah give me five
that's a great prior joke uh he goes uh
sorry honey i just need some new [ __ ]
he goes well if you had two more inches
you get some new [ __ ] here
oh wow that's a great great
self-deprecating
prior dick joke self-deprecating on on
two levels i love it
it's i i just don't like the traffic
thing because it's like
best case i don't giving the best case
we always give the best case scenario
with traffic
right i want the worst
or the worst when though i don't think
we give the worst no no we should give
the worst because that way if you're
early
it's a plus right but it's like i don't
do that with any other part of my life
it's never like sam how are you good if
i can win the lottery you're like all
right
you didn't win the lottery and you're
not going to there's going to be traffic
it's new york
that's so true people do that with
everything like hey how you got a big
dick
i'm eight inches on a good day well what
the [ __ ] is a good day
what does that mean a good dick day yeah
i mean la they do this all the time
they're like uh you know la
without traffic and you're like when has
there not been traffic in los angeles
exactly so true you can't really do that
with air travel which is nice
because there's no traffic up there so
it's never like how long does it take to
get to new york oh you know eight eight
hours without traffic
it's just five hours that's it
yeah well speaking of things that annoy
us here's one thing that doesn't annoy
us
we might be drunk is brought to you by
honey
uh you you love honey mark love the
honey big fan these guys
this this is one of those things you're
like how did this not come out earlier
yeah i mean it's basically it's discount
codes but you don't have to like i mean
i used to do this i would google
i'd be on a website be like google for
discount code for that website and you
get it sometimes it would work sometimes
it won't
yeah this place it just scans the
internet and gets you the best deal
every time honey
yes thanks to honey i don't have to
search anymore we all shop online but
having this promo code ready to go
is tough honey is the free browser
extension that scours the internet for
discount codes when you're ready to
check out
honey automatically applies the best one
instant savings
honey has found its customers over 2
billion
clams in savings supported by over 30
000 stores online
buy anything from tech and gaming to
beer and wine
there you go that's for us yeah we love
it get on it
tell them how to do it sammy it's
literally it's free if you don't have
honey
you could be missing out on free savings
it's free installs in just a few seconds
save some dough and support this podcast
get honey for free
join it's join honey.com
drunk so it's not just honey it's join
honey dot com
slash drunk that supports us and
supports honey and it supports yourself
so get that honey baby
yes you know it takes like
six years to make a gram of honey or
something some horrible stat where
you're like ah geez
it was a movie about it in macedonia
uh-huh
there was that beekeeper woman in
macedonia and it's like
it's the most tragic [ __ ] you're just
like yeah because that's all she does
it's like really about
everything i forgot the name of it it's
a uh harry maybe you could let us know
the name of that movie beekeeper woman
in macedonia it just came out like a
year ago
it was it was one of the most i think it
could nominate for an oscar for
documentary and it's like
this woman who just makes her own honey
she's like got a horrible life she's got
like no teeth
wow and then this new family comes in
and they're like abusing
the protocol on how you make honey ah
and
and it's like they take and she's like
no there's there's a system so you don't
get stung and so you you good to the
bees and you give them honey back as
well it's called honey land
thanks harry and uh better than the
jessica alba movie honey
uh but jessica alba looked better though
but uh i mean
macedonia [ __ ] man like that that has
got to be a tough place to live where is
that is that eastern bloc
let me get the exact location tried i
did a bit about it
um oh wow well like uh
yeah it's it's yeah it's like eastern
southeast europe uh i did a bit about
how i didn't know it was still
like because the facebook breach was in
macedonia
it's the one of the facebook breaches
originally started macedonia and i was
like i don't even know that was still a
place
that was one of the angles like i was
like i was like man this sounds like a
babylonian time travel breach that was
part of the
i bet they teamed up with the with the
mesopotamians for this one that was my
angle
right right yeah the byzantine empire or
something
but that you always hear these things
like without bees we wouldn't have
uh wi-fi or or you know
sugar or whatever the hell it is and
you're like geez i didn't know the bees
were that important
yeah and then she would like go to these
weird little farmers markets and make
money off it like she would sell it to
people that's how she'd make money but
uh
yeah it was like the freshest honey ever
i'll watch that
it's yeah it's pretty it's pretty heavy
but it's good and uh
[ __ ] man it's a tough life it's a tough
life
i love a good duck and that's the beauty
of a dock you don't have to give a [ __ ]
about
the premise it's just if it's well done
you just get sucked in and
also honey never goes bad that's
incredible is that true
never true story true story give it a
good harry
give it a go never goes bad it's pretty
cool it's like this magical elixir you
know the bees
[ __ ] and they make it then then those
those crazy things where if you if you
trap the queen bee
all the other bees will chase like if
you put it in a little jar they'll just
chase the jar you can throw the jar down
a well they'll all go down the well
pretty badass there's there's no there's
no
like [ __ ] individual b like i do my own
thing
you know you're all they're all in line
apparently uh yeah if you've trapped the
the queen bee she yells out uh
rigged rigged election and then all the
other bees they storm the
right right but
man yeah honey is the best man i like a
little spicy honey
oh good todd berry uh you do that on
your on your pizza
no a little spicy honey on your pizza
game changer dude
whoa i mean i thought ranch was crazy
enough
some people were ranch on their pizza
i've never even heard of spicy honey
it's good a lot of like the cool new
york pizza places do it now it's [ __ ]
good i
gotta load my apartment i'll throw some
of my [ __ ] yogurt i'll go crazy
interesting there's all these weird
little
[ __ ] concoctions you know there's the
the french fries in the wendy's frosty
i'm sure you heard of that one
oh no god no oh that's big that sounds
good
ah i don't like salty sweet
what no i'm not for me i do that sounds
like
i just wouldn't want a soggy fry people
rave
people rave about it that's a big one
salt on watermelon was big
in louisiana some like the old guy put
salt on it and we were like whoa
this guy's crazy salty and sweet man
yeah yeah not for me i like i you know
those apples with a [ __ ] mandarin
orange and a cranberry get out of here
yeah the big one the italians do is the
prosciutto and melon that's a big one
yes
watermelon and feta is a big one no no
yeah i will swear by
by a pickle and peanut butter sandwich
you ever get into that no
no i'm segregating food i i don't like
all that mixing
i'm like a 50s preacher when it comes to
food i don't want the
i'll put nuts on ice cream or something
like that but
melon and meat not for me yeah
i'm okay with that a little prosciutto
melons good yeah most people like it i'm
just i'm just a weirdo
how about how about how about like a
chex mix salty and sweet will you do
that nah
nah nah no thank you yeah
you never did the the uh
like the m m's and the popcorn or
anything
oh no thank you no thank you
i'll do i'll do a salted caramel that's
about as far as i'll go over doing salty
sweet that's that's oh those are [ __ ]
that's the best
that's the best that i love but yeah
eminem and papa it's
it's too much that's the queen bee of
the of the salty and sweet i think the
the salted caramel i would say i agree
yeah
big fan what i got more peeves i don't
know if you could anymore
i love the peeves all right all right
how about this one this one drives me
nuts
uh i was with a guy last weekend i
didn't want to say it
too much because i didn't want to give
it away who it was but
you ever got you ever hang out with the
guy with the teeth suck you know this
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
you ever have that one with the the
tongue through the teeth
yeah it's a weird one what is that i'm
right here it it
it's grossing me out it's all i could
hear from this guy and it was driving me
crazy
yeah that's [ __ ] weird so why is he
doing that it's like a nervous tick or
something
i think it's a tick you know just just
bored like
ah yeah that's pretty bad and then
can i call that out or am i the [ __ ]
it's tough it's tough it's tough because
we don't there's certain things we don't
know where the line is we're like
i've been told that by people that
you're like sam you made comments about
that
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] like i've been
told that by people i care about they're
like you gotta just shut the [ __ ] up
right right a nice way i'll be like
you're right or something
but they say someone told me recently
like you have a very calm way of saying
really cruel things really yes
whoa damn that's interesting
wow
that's true but here's my thing i would
rather
just take the teeth sucking and live
with it and be in hell
then embarrass the guy
yeah for sure i don't want to i don't
want to like hurt someone's feelings
no i don't either and and these are a
bunch of sensitive
you know kweefy comics so they'll be
like oh geez i'm sorry but i'm like i
know i know it's not
it's nothing personal i just that sound
just makes me want to kill myself
yeah sometimes you just get used to it
though if you just kind of
if you just it's harder for me when i
don't know the person and you're stuck
like if it's someone i know i kind of
will eventually just get used to it but
if it's something if i'm like on a
flight with someone and they they're
just next to me doing weird [ __ ] like
that i'm just like
all right here we go oh that's the worst
and then but here's my problem this is
where i suck because
i'll have a few drinks we're hanging out
we're getting close and chummy
and then i'll do a passive aggressive
joke like well as bob he's he's
sucking his teeth all night over here
and he's like huh and i'm like oh no i
let it out
happens every time yeah
it's time little things bother me like
like stranger [ __ ] bothers me like a
peeve of mine like i was i'm trying to
meditate a little more just because
funny see articles like people who
meditate uh
better blood pressure they're more
healthy and you're like yeah people that
are consciously concerned with their
health
are going to be like a lot of [ __ ]
heroin addicts who meditate
yeah they're probably better off they do
on accident
[Laughter]
but um you know
yeah i think didn't dc benny used to
have a bit about like i saw a guy i
thought he was doing tai chi what was it
that was doing great in the park and i
was a heroin addict
yeah fall over yeah great so
but you know i'm in a [ __ ] cab i'm
trying to meditate i'm waiting
a gig i'm just having anxiety so i'm
meditating and the guy's on
he's not only like checking in on me
nonstop he's on speakerphone so he's
having two conversations
oh he was unspeakable in the whole time
so i'm like let me just try to zone him
out let me just try but it's hard when
someone's like loudly like laughing
you're just like oh boy well he's having
a good time
he turned in and be like you okay you
okay back there and i'd be like oh yeah
i'm just trying to
meditate and be like okay keep me put
like he's like oh let me know
let me know like if i can do anything he
goes it's uh you got enough air back
there and i'm like i got plenty of air
there's a yeah there's a lot of air the
window's popped everything's good
all right let me know it goes cool
enough i'm just like please i'm just
trying to
i'm just trying to disconnect from the
world yeah see that one's tough because
you can never
relax completely because you're like oh
what was that oh [ __ ] because you have
to be a little awake to keep responding
so you kind of go in and out of it which
is almost worse
yeah that's a tough one
give me another well i had an uber
driver today it's [ __ ]
five in the morning we're on the way to
the airport and he's blaring
kings of leon just blaring it
and i can barely you know hear myself
jizz and then he goes uh
vacation or you're going on vacation and
i was like huh
so not only is the music annoying but
now you're trying to to have a chit chat
with the loud so i just at one point i
went i can't hear what you're saying the
music's too loud and he
he turned the music down he's like you
going on vacation are you coming from
vacation i was like i'm going home and
it was just the worst
worst conversation i pulled i'm going to
[ __ ] hell
i know i pulled this one i go uh
hey buddy i might pass out don't take it
personal
and then he was like oh yeah go go nuts
so i feel like i pulled that off but
then he turns the music back up exactly
that's exactly what he did but i have
the the earbuds with the sound canceling
it doesn't do enough though no that [ __ ]
here's the problem with the early
morning
uh uber driver versus the early morning
traveler
we're [ __ ] exhausted and they're
doing whatever they can to stay awake
they've got their big rock star energy
their [ __ ]
yep lasting music and they're blasting
music because
it's like you kind of can't fault them
because you're like yeah if i was
driving a
car at 5 00 a.m i need to do
i need to be playing like my pump up mix
you know totally and you're bored as
[ __ ] from just
circling the wagons all day so you're
like what's up with this guy what's he
do for a living so you're just kind of
trying to stimulate yourself
you got your dead wife's ashes on the
dashboard you got your [ __ ] dream
catcher on the on the mirror
this guy's miserable put on a podcast
get a book on tape
yeah it's tough you kind of wish yeah
it's tough it's it's shared
shared space is where all the problems
happen in the world that's where [ __ ]
dude that's that's so true i mean look
at rich people
everything rich people do is about being
away from the general pop
first class then to private jet then
to a mansion on the hills with their own
acreage it's all about getting away from
the yokels
i mean [ __ ] the middle east to a
roommate
it's about space right it's all about
space it's all about space
i mean think about you know that
roommate you have where you're like
[ __ ]
they're in the common area all the time
yeah and you're like
oh i gotta i gotta like now make small
every time i go by right how's it going
how are you going to the bathroom
a lot sorry hey how's it going again got
to grow on there
nice that you're out here and you can
hear everything happening in there right
how are you
great eye contact with you yeah it's
brutal
it's all about space and i think like
and there's not enough people
yeah and i look out we've all been broke
uh
you got to take an uber pool which is
now you're sharing you got to take the
greyhound now you're on the bus with a
bunch of weirdos and
and guys playing casino games at full
volume and eating
peking duck for some reason you know
like
it's all about being around other people
you don't know and then yeah rich people
it's the exact
opposite yeah it's like a child
space and isolation is like the ultimate
luxury i think
ultimate luxury i mean look what a spa
is just you in a room with a bunch of
people humming and like a trinkling of a
of a water fountain you got the
cucumbers
isolation isolation is either the best
or the worst that's what i was gonna say
you got the [ __ ] uh the prison guy
yeah you know who lives in isolation
[ __ ] uh
jeffrey dahmer and ellen degeneres
solitary confinement you know what else
but then you know who lived in isolation
bernie madoff
and now again bernie madoff
write it down that's killer all right
that's a bit
and clean it's a clean bit we're talking
clean bits
yes it's uh more superior
so true made off and made off that's
great
madoff that's that was that's a great
name for a firm
made up and made off you're getting
[ __ ] either way
what uh any other peeves uh well this
one is so silly i mean i i feel dumb
even bringing it up but it's a me thing
and i don't think it'll be relatable to
any other human being on the planet but
i love these though these are the
personal ones all right
i did a shoot like a little video shoot
for a friend
and it was super fun super easy show up
shoot for an hour be funny we'll edit it
and tag it all that great no problem
pays a couple couple shekels great
that's the job was to just do this video
at the end of it they go
all right just send me an invoice and uh
we'll pay you and i'm like what invoice
i don't know how to do that well just
get a pdf and put all your information
like pdf whoa
that's greek to me and now now to me
that's the work
the invoice is the work the other [ __ ]
was just fun and easy
i i can't do an invoice so i'm googling
invoices i'm like do i need i'm done
i hate it nightmare i'm like how do i
convert this to i'm on word not gonna go
to pdf or
or jpeg or whatever the [ __ ] so the the
the
invoice was the hardest part of the
whole gig yeah it's it's it's insane
like look who you hired dude we got good
assistant we got good at this
talking like saying inappropriate [ __ ]
to strangers in a bar
and you're and you're asking me to
[ __ ] do paperwork like
i i do this so i don't have to do that
[ __ ] problem is when you do gigs around
your agent man they handle all that they
handle the annoying [ __ ]
that's why yeah we can say whatever we
want about the
industry but like they do the [ __ ] we
don't want to do man
like when you have a good rep you don't
notice that [ __ ]
i know that fine print i mean it's
stacks of contracts and signatures and
all that [ __ ] and
i don't wanna i mean you could be
screwing me out of thousands and i'm
like it's worth it you you fill that
[ __ ] out
oh i don't yeah i'll pay it out dude the
comedy central thing we both just did
that uh
that roast thing man it's like five
contracts
i know i know and it's so stupid like in
the words of jay leno it doesn't have to
be this difficult
you give me the gig i'll do it give me
the money why is it five
it's one of those things where i'm just
like you guys know
yeah it's what and these are the ones
where they need your signature on so you
can't even have your
reps cheated for you we're just inside
baseball complaining folks but uh
right right no it is a thing where
you're just like also they take the
longest to [ __ ] pay you
of anything i know we're just like hey
can you can we make sure we get the
money before you guys collapse
because yes exactly
so true so true you guys are a crumbling
industry i have more followers than you
what does that tell you
now you're taking six weeks to pay me
it's kind of freaking me out
oh god they fired like all the good
people though i mean there's still good
people that work there but they fired so
many [ __ ] good people there and
you're just like god damn it
[ __ ] yeah what are you gonna do yeah
yeah
it's it's a tough world and look that
that's the business aspect and it sucks
and on the flip side
i know some people who aren't comics who
love the instinct invoice
that's a [ __ ] that's a nothing that's
a
i'm batting an eye i can knock out an
invoice i'm like oh that invoice
for me is like i gotta i gotta turn the
phone off i gotta lock the door
you know uh take an adderall and then i
knock it out but then some people can
just do that [ __ ]
with their eyes closed you have to do
drugs to do the easy part
that's [ __ ] great yeah yeah no i mean
but that's that is for most people just
collecting the money but for us it's
like we have become
almost like autistic joke people we're
like
where we can only really focus on like
anything that's not
comedy for me is hard to focus on
anything that's not
like when i when i disengage from comedy
for too long
it's like being an addict who doesn't
have a drink you're just like you start
being like [ __ ] i need i get anxiety i
need to write a joke or need to at least
like thinking of a joke
even if it's not so it's so when i'm
doing the business stuff i'm like this
is a waste of time and time is all we
have
right right i could originally [ __ ]
pay us
exactly exactly so yeah i'm with you
look at norm mcdonnell he's one of the
funniest guys on the planet he doesn't
know how to drive
you barely can drive you know we need
that room in our brain for
jokes i remember joe list would give me
so much [ __ ] for that gig well
well i was like i'll do some of the
driving we did like a run of casinos he
did 30 hours i did about half an
hour he was so mad at me
the whole time he was so hilarious but
it's like look man i'm worried for us
like i
i think we're getting a car crash while
i'm driving i'm doing this for you man
oh man the [ __ ] music i'm i'm dj and
he's like i [ __ ] hate you so much i'm
like
hey you like bobby darren he's like
[ __ ] kill yourself
bobby darren oh that's great
he's like you dry you don't even drive
me crazy you're just making me crazy
because you can't drive
what's the deal with anal all right oh
that's when he started hating me when he
was dry he barely knew me i'm like what
do you think of this joke i was just
scanning down jokes
he was like this guy's a [ __ ] lunatic
he hated me well he was texting me the
whole time he's like
this guy's a [ __ ] joke monster he
just put
like pulling jokes out of his ass and
then he's like it's annoying the hell
out of me
and then he saw you on stage he's like
this guy's got a million jokes and i'm
like yeah where do you think they come
from
i mean yeah that was when joe still
drank that was like oh
yeah that was when i was like oh [ __ ] oh
i guess he's a better driver than me
drunk
so what are you gonna do yeah still
better that's hilarious
um here's a peeve people who people who
respond
to a self-deprecating remark with uh
with like oof or uh like you
you make some a self-deprecating comment
about yourself and they're just like oh
boy
yeah it's like you're [ __ ] on me
[ __ ] on myself
right right now are they saying that's a
bad joke or like this makes me
uncomfortable
probably both oh yeah
i think it's more just like you're
making me i think people are
uncomfortable when people make
self-deprecating remarks because like
a lot of people like how often do you go
on like the road or something and you
make like a therapy comment and they're
just like
what they're just like ugh like like i
think we are
we'll talk about ourselves in a way that
like
i think i made a joke about i just have
a joke about like
how every guy likes some you know it was
like a therapy joke about like wanting
to [ __ ] your mom
and it's like and they were like oh and
i was like you never heard that concept
before i'm not saying i want to actually
[ __ ] my mom
i'm saying it's like it's it's like
freud it's
[ __ ] page one man i'm so with you i
hate any of that [ __ ] where yeah you
make fun of yourself i used to have this
one in high school or i'd like try to
talk to a girl
and i would say some dark thing about me
and then go okay
[Music]
i hate the okay shut the [ __ ] up okay
yeah
yeah that's like it's like the
equivalent of you texting someone and
they just write back
dot dot dot
that's what it feels like right it's
evil
wow yeah i don't even like a dot dot dot
after someone says something like it's
because of this
dot dot dot it's like it's like just
call me a [ __ ] idiot
exactly just say you're [ __ ] stupid
that's like the clean version of being
like you're dumb
right it's yeah it's so condescending
and then you feel stupid and
self-conscious after you so you can't
really
be yourself anymore it ruins everything
the whole relationship's [ __ ]
yeah everything's [ __ ] i don't like i
just you're being you're being
i don't like people responding it's like
i remember uh i did a prom show back in
the day
uh with a comic and he went up there and
he was [ __ ] on himself and the and
people in the crowd they're young so
they don't get to like
right awareness is the power they don't
get to like
so they would he would [ __ ] himself
and he'd be like oh i haven't had sex in
this long and people be like ha ha
and i was like no he wrote the joke he's
aware of it you know
yes it was like it's almost like that
level of thinking
yeah yeah god people are [ __ ] idiots
jesus they were at least kids and
insecure but you're just like
those those gigs were fun though because
these are like 16 year old kids and you
could just go look at the virgin they
all go
ah [ __ ] oh billy is a virgin that guy's
never had a [ __ ] and it's live on
you're murdering just by calling them
dorks yeah well i remember
i go up and try to do material and the
second i start bombing i'd be like
looking for targets i'm like this
[ __ ]
yeah i'm like this dude's gonna shoot
the school up isn't it everyone's like
yeah
that's the big one shoot the school he
he's obsessed with jerking him see jerks
off too much and
that works that's like a blanket because
that works on everybody because it's
every
high school kid and uh you know he's got
a crush on jenny and they're like oh
[ __ ] he does you know the kids are so
insecure that they're like freaking out
yeah it's [ __ ] there's always my
favorite part of the prom show is
there's always like
a few kids that get like carried out
pissed drunk like that's like a real new
york prom show
you're like security's got to carry some
kids like vomiting in the back i'm like
this kid [ __ ] face and everyone's like
yeah
[Laughter]
that was me back in the day by the way
but yeah no it's so true that
it's fascinating even when i do a
college gig every joke about having a
job is out
every joke about being like paying my
bills is out like they have no life
experience yet and it's kind of tough
right you got to go like basic year one
stuff you got to do like you got to
think what did i find funny when i was
like 18
and like you could still do dating jokes
that's like yeah that's why dating jokes
are so [ __ ] good because
uh kids will still find that stuff funny
that's true and look those jokes are
they're the most bulletproof concept as
long as you have a good angle because
everyone's had their heart broken
everyone's had dating
problems everyone like it's it's the
most bulletproof
of any of any premise subject
chris yeah it's so relatable chris rock
would always say end on the relationship
stuff
that's the biggest you know relatability
brings the whole room together
everybody gets it it hits home for
everybody so that's that's how you got
to close
interesting yeah that's smart um
what do you think it depends what do you
got
because that way you get them all on
board and then you can kind of say
whatever you want like for me
rock i guess is famous enough that he
can open on political [ __ ] or open on
like a social point
but for me it's kind of like if i open
on relationship stuff
we're all on the same side they see me
as one of them and and i feel connected
to them and now i can say
the [ __ ] up jokes i do the same method
i end on the heavy [ __ ]
yeah i mean i think that's that's that's
rock being [ __ ] famous and also great
obviously but
right right yeah i've got a wreck for
you all right i want to kill out of the
gate so i can get yeah i want to get
their trust
what do you do you got a good wreck i
got a i got a wreck yeah
uh i watched the biggie smalls dock it
was pretty good
yeah i should watch that it's pretty
good i mean i love anything about rags
to riches like how did they get from
you know bed stuy or whatever the hell
he was to to you know the top of the
mountain
in the hip-hop world and it it
chronicles the whole thing and the stuff
i didn't even know about the guy and i
thought it was
pretty well done yeah i think like
i think hip-hop would have been in such
a better place if i mean it's the most
obvious statement ever if
biggie and pop were alive man i mean
they were so yeah they were just so good
i mean yeah but it's like whenever you
lose someone who's so important
to the art form you're just like man
what a bummer it's like
you know just not having like louie in
the mainstream has been bad for comedy i
think it's like yeah
patrice patrice geraldo yeah yeah
totally totally you need those
pillars i guess you'd say and and he was
24 when he died
that's insane insane so he had so much
to go
yeah he didn't even scratch the surface
but
but then there's the bill hicks argument
like well
what if jimi hendrix didn't die at 27
and then he
uh started doing pepsi ads or you know a
t commercials or whatever
well even bill hicks would have been
like you're a [ __ ] corporate sellout
if you do any commercials you're a piece
of [ __ ] you're [ __ ] scum
uh your next dad is lucy's nicotine
yeah it's true this has been brought to
you by lucy's nicotine
yeah which by the way uh we're loving
lucy's nicotine gum man they've been
good to us
they really this company was founded by
caltech scientists
and smokers who uh who wanted other
people to quit
you don't like gum they got the cherry
ice lozenge mark they got
uh great flavors of gum no winter green
cinnamon pomegranate
four milligrams of nicotine this will
help you quit smoking and actually taste
good i i've heard
yeah they've got great flavors winter
green cinnamon and pomegranate and you
get the lozenge if you don't like
chewing gum the cherry ice
so yeah get uh get lucy so you're
prepared
to fight that itch cut out because it's
hard to quit smoking man it's
we know a lot of smokers out there oh
yeah oh yeah they're a dying breed
but uh yeah it's tough i mean it's one
of the hardest things there's books on
it
and uh this is the way to go i mean you
still get that nicotine but you just
don't have to inhale the
[ __ ] rat turds and tar exactly would
you want to read a book
or do you want to just choose some gum
and watch a new biggie doc
yeah there you go uh get a pack of lucy
and get that monkey off your back
subscribe and i'll show you
show up at your it'll show up at your
door each month so you'll always be
ready
they're supporting this show so go
support them 20 off all products
including gum or
lozenges at lucy.co with code
drunk that's 20 off lucy.co and use
promo code
drunk at checkout and we got to say this
for the lawyers
this product does contain nicotine
derived from tobacco nicotine is an
addictive chemical
no duh get 20 off at lucy.co with code
drunk
and quit those sticks today
i got a good wreck for you i'm sure
you've seen it yeah i've never seen it
miller's crossing oh
cohen brothers i never i love the cone
brothers so much i think they're
probably the best filmmakers of our
generation but uh
probably yeah but i've never seen that
one it's beautifully shot
irish italian gangster flick great cast
great series
great dialogue there's like a line so
you want to kill him
for starters that's a great lie
that's great yeah i mean that movie was
shot but part of that was shot in new
orleans and i remember being a kid
and seeing some of the shooting of it
and be like what's this and some guy was
like it's miller's crossing i was like
what the hell is miller's crossing
and uh then it you know came out but
yeah
so good i mean just just a film
yeah it's beautiful and it's and it's
badass and it's
cool apparently it bombed hard they got
the money to make it because of raising
arizona
right and then they made the movie they
really want to make and it [ __ ] did
not a great cast too but
yeah big bomb yes so many i love those
like noir lines or like marcia gay hard
and then and
you know he he's honest and he's got a
heart then it's true what they say
opposites attract
[Laughter]
so good [ __ ] but i mean it also goes to
show you like it's such great
art by these two geniuses and yet
it's a bomb but like yeah that's just
how
the industry goes like raising arizona
was great killed
this was great bomb just not for
everybody and you got to remember that
as a as an artist
yeah you got to remember that like
you're also building something right
like that movie like you're building a
fan base you're building die-hards it
was critically acclaimed
so that's true that's true you're
building a base
you know i i think i think that's what i
mean
yeah is there is there any uh jewish uh
you know love there like hey these guys
are a couple of
jews and they're killing it are they
jews oh come on
they've gotta be yeah right serious man
they've gotta be right and
cohen i don't know i assume yeah but i
think it's cone is it's usually spelled
c-o-h-e-n for jews aha
i don't know give that a goog i would
assume they work because they're
you know talented yeah they're jewish
they're jewish yeah i know
i i mean i i just think they're that
great that like it would make sense to
me they could make a movie like a
serious man without even being jewish
but yeah it's
that was a great movie too great movie
yeah man another their killer um no i
don't know if it i mean i just i like
good filmmakers i don't know i like uh i
mean i [ __ ] love tarantino i i mean
yeah that's true good point i mean i
don't know i just uh like a point of
pride you mean
yeah because you know when when like
harvey [ __ ] up your mom's like oh
[ __ ] jew so i wonder if it's when
it's a good jew you're like hey that's
one for us
now i just think like i think it's uh
i mean yeah it's cool but it's also like
i didn't do anything
that was like that's true obviously it
is funny when people are like
when they have this like pride where
you're like yeah i was born
uh you know jewish but well
i didn't make any movies but you know
where it's nice
is like when there's anti-semites and
you're like
you ever read [ __ ] marvel
you ever watch no country old men you
ever enjoy stand-up comedy
right here that's when it's nice when
you get to shove it in some
some bigots face yeah i haven't had
i haven't had that issue really like
jews suck and i'm like oh yeah
well come to my parties
i'm not reading the reddit uh the reddit
threads
they're like i wasn't having any issues
at the capitol holy should you see
jay johnston from mr show at the capitol
yeah
crazy huh [ __ ] crazy i didn't know
he's a little older so maybe there's
something there but like this guy was on
sarah silverman show and uh such a comic
actor
so weird crazy crazy you know what's
annoying me is like all this shit's
going on in the world and like
everyone's like and so what
like i know you're following the dr
seuss [ __ ] it's so stupid all over yeah
and it's like
it's just like like who gives a [ __ ]
it's like i know because
they'll go on tv like this is cans i
hate i hate it is a peeve
is a lot of people
are just using the word cancelled for
anything now and i'm like right
no cancel means you got canceled it
doesn't mean like no one canceled dr
seuss that's what i'm just like and also
like like it was his [ __ ] own company
that did it they were like we're just
gonna
discontinue this you could still get all
his other [ __ ] yeah cancel is like nazi
where we're just using it too
exactly or racist you know we just throw
it out there because it's a big word now
it's buzzy yeah
so yeah it's not good because uh some
[ __ ] does get canceled and now you're
you're uh minimizing that yeah my
ancestors got canceled
by nazis yay there we go
exactly um yeah no it's annoying to me
well that leads into my my my bid idea
if you're ready for it please so i was i
was watching a nazi documentary
and uh these nazis did all these crazy
experiments on the jews like all these
medical weirdo
you know take this kid and make him take
his arm off and put it on this guy all
this crazy [ __ ]
and obviously we stopped it but
we still kept the information which i
found interesting like we still retained
that like hey if they did it already
might as well learn from it
and i thought that was interesting and
it reminded me of cat calling
like look catcalling women hate it it's
a bad thing
but you still get information out of it
you know like some girl walks down the
street
and some guy's like damn your ass looks
good in those jeans and she's like [ __ ]
you i'm not a piece of meat
but i'll wear these tomorrow
could be something there you can still
get a piece good information out of a
horrible event
yeah i look i love that i love that ass
and she's just like you [ __ ] monster
but like also thank you
yeah thank you for noticing thank you
for exactly
you're a pig but i got some intel intel
is a good word for that yeah yeah
yeah you're a pig but we got some
information
still valuable it might not be the best
delivery method but it was still
something i can use yeah it's bad and we
don't condone it
but if you have to do it exactly
you may as well take some notes right
right you may as well
i'm trying if there's anything else
other than cat corn even further at like
uh
man that was it's
yeah i get a cat call is probably the
right call because it's like it's hard
to go you can't
go darker than the [ __ ] holocaust you
gotta reel it in with something more
silly like cat car yeah right you might
be right
catcalling huh 911 because we learned a
lot of like security stuff with 911 but
that's also dark but that's too dark
yeah you don't want it you don't want to
go 911 from you want to go
somewhere lighter which is probably why
coin's the right move
what about like something a little more
broad like hey
in the back in the day when your buddy
ate a berry and it killed him
it's horrible but now we know those are
poisonous
it's still dark but it's it's uh it's
not specific
what were they what were the tests they
did on the jews oh
all kinds of like just weird medical
[ __ ] like we'll rip an arm off this kid
and sew it to that kid and see if it
works or
or make twins do this [ __ ] and that [ __ ]
and cut the leg off a twin it was it was
horrible stuff
i'm thinking the way
yeah you're starting so dark you've
gotta you've gotta go
you gotta bring it in you know yeah yeah
i think cat calling is the one
it's yeah that that should do it that's
the big punch
does it hit i did it a couple times and
it does well but it's
it feels like a dark road to get to that
silly punch so yeah i think
some lightning is a good idea
because we were like whoa holocaust
experiment whoa how'd we get here
there's a lot of that yeah it's people
people [ __ ] hate even uh people are
people are tough yeah yeah but all right
well what do you got i got i had this
thing about like when you see an x
with a new guy on social media or
something when they post a new picture
some guy's like a friend asked me like
why does that make you feel and i was
like
you know what it feels like it feels
like uh it feels like i served in iraq
and then i came back from iraq and then
i saw
another guy post a picture in iraq
do you know what i mean yeah you know i
tried to bring peace there too
wasn't my place right right yeah like
good on you but uh you're in for a
a [ __ ] storm that's an uphill battle
right there right
right right i'm i'm glad i went i'm glad
i got out but uh
i don't know if i could do it again yeah
i mean it's hot
it's hot it's hot
it's hot but it's it it ends dirty or
something
you come back and it it'll [ __ ] you up
yeah you're a different guy after that
you're a little scary
i might need to i might need to preface
it with being like i'm a [ __ ] and i
could never serve in there just right
right right but
i would assume it was like maybe if i go
in like that
also my grandfather was in korea and
he wouldn't talk about it so that could
be funny too so i was like oh how's how
you doing with the breakup you're like
and somebody's like what are you doing
don't talk don't bring that up he's
shell-shocked
yeah how does someone rope you back in
after uh yeah they're like
yeah maybe they hit you up they're like
would you ever be down for another tour
and you're like oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah oh you uh right
right you hook up again you're like i
was in the reserves you know they called
me back
yeah the idea of like not
the idea that there's something to that
like when you're in the war
you're like you're in the best shape of
your life you're doing push-ups every
day you're doing
training and then when you get out of
the war you're like you get a little
fatter you get a little lazier
you know you have to be in like
relationship shape
yeah you look you look a little [ __ ]
up
too yeah yeah you're done you're like
i'm in bed yeah
there's there's a lot here i'll play
with this one there's a lot there yeah
we should also
we should also shout out um our patreon
which is growing thank you guys
patreon.com we might be drunk pod
join up you get a second episode we read
your peeves
should we should we do one right now
let's read a peep get the get their
beaks wet a little bit
get the beaks wet brother all right pepe
from
ollie felicioni hey hey love the pod
there's nothing better than waking up
monday with a fresh app i got a big time
peeve
when people say hey why are you
complaining when you
when you're clearly not complaining like
let me give you an example my ta
was grading our papers very harshly for
the first several weeks
but he seemed to ease up for some reason
recently after getting 70s and 80s
i just got a 99 100 the past two weeks
and my friend said the same thing so
i'm texting my friend i'm saying how
weird uh
we're all out of all of a sudden we're
just getting better grades and of course
he responds
why are you complaining i'm not
complaining you [ __ ] guzzling nazi is
what he wrote
i'm just saying it's strange that's a
good you're making an observation people
are like yeah stop complaining that's a
good point
i had a similar peeve on like the second
app
hey there's free pizza at this bar how'd
that happen why are you complaining i'm
not i'm just questioning it can we
can we observe some things that it might
be unusual
[ __ ] hilarious imagine if seinfeld
like hung out like have you ever noticed
this
stop complaining all right i won't do
comedy sorry right right good point
gonna be he'd have no act yeah people
observe things i'm with you ollie [ __ ]
that
[ __ ] yeah people but i can't wait for
the pandemic to be over so i can see you
guys live well we can't wait man uh yeah
thanks for listening
leave us a nice review on itunes tell
your friends
and uh anything else oh i'm doing a
virtual show on march 22nd so you can
get tickets to that on
my website i also have some live dates
coming on so just go to sammorrell.com
shows mark where are you going to be man
hell yeah hell yeah i'm uh i'm all over
the road as well at
marknormancomedy.com uh coming to a town
near you
things are starting to open up so dates
are pouring in so i'm sure i'm coming
near you
and then uh what else our instagrams or
twitters
follow our instagram page oh we might be
drunk on insta we got videos we got
uh fun fun photos and jokes and stuff so
yeah a lot a lot of stuff to file a lot
of content
and tell a friend and keep drinking keep
drinking guys thank you